matthew stafford speaking to the detroit
free press on the way out of town
specifically
to mitch album and among other things
matthew stafford said that he also had a
left elbow injury to go with thumb rib
and ankle injuries in 2020 the elbow was
never disclosed he started wearing a
wrap at some point after the
thanksgiving game so the elbow was
another problem the guy has always
played through
anything and everything he is very
physically
tough there was a column over the
weekend from carlos monres of the
detroit free press that raised
and articulated a concern i've had about
stafford
and what monterey said is through 12
years he's never seen stafford as one of
these quarterbacks who is obsessed with
greatness who is obsessed with winning
who is obsessed with legacy just kind of
like hey i work here there's not much i
can do about it and peter that's what's
been odd to me you know would peyton
manning have tolerated 12 years of crap
in detroit or would he have either fixed
it himself or gotten the hell out of
there tom brady would he have tolerated
12 years of that in detroit you fix it
yourself or you get the hell out of
there and stafford has played at a high
level but they've put nothing around him
and look where russell wilson is right
now and he's won a super bowl for crying
out loud he's been to another so
i just feel like with stafford there is
a fair criticism to be made that he's
never truly demanded the kind of
greatness that we're used to seeing from
great quarterbacks
you know mike i i probably am more on
the side with people who say that i
think he's going to really play well
with the rams
um
i mean we can talk about the importance
of
how important it is to sean mcvay i i
don't know that he's going to get a
third quarterback mike
you know i i i'm exaggerating there a
little bit but because i mean there's
sean mcvay i think is an excellent
football coach but they've spent an
awful lot of capital right now uh you
know on the quarterback position
and it's not like they can keep
throwing draft picks and money at this
problem
but what i'm saying is and so i believe
that
matthew stafford is a great fit for sean
mcvay and i think it will work
however
i just don't think you can say
that oh my god he never had any players
he always had bad coaches
calvin johnson island there
he had calvin johnson when he showed up
for the first half of his career or
however many years it was
uh and then he he's always had a good
receiving crew hasn't he okay he hasn't
had a great running game i get that
but you know to say that he's had nobody
around him
is just it's just wrong
and and the others get drafted first
overall
all right
and you get drafted first overall and
you never win a playoff game and you
never win your division there's only
four teams in your division in 12 years
you never win the division
and so it's statistically impossible
all i can say is all i can say is
i like this move
for the line for the for the rams i
really like the move for the rams
but
you know it's not like matthew stafford
comes in writing on a white steed he's
got something to prove here
well and and look just
it's possible that both things are true
that it was partially on stafford
that the team stunk for 12 years and he
didn't demand
more
and it's also possibly true that sean
mcvay
is going to
say to matthew stafford just do what you
did for the last 12 years will take care
of the rest and you know he will be
united with aaron donald a guy the lions
could have and frankly should have taken
instead of eric ebert in 2014 they're
entering the last year of the endowment
consu contract the last year of the nick
failing fairly contract they only had
like one defensive tackle who was under
contract beyond that season and they
didn't take aaron donald so there have
been flaws in detroit and there has been
success with the rams peter but i'm with
you let's give it a a a wait and see and
maybe the rams will be better with
stafford
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports